hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book one of saint augustine's
confessions starting in chapter six
there is a discussion
of infancy and specifically
augustine's own infancy which he doesn't
know but has to infer about
and you might say well what is that
doing in there well this is a spiritual
autobiography so it makes sense that he
would talk about uh all the phases of
his life up until the point where he's
he's writing the book
and
infancy is part of that we all come into
the world as little babies and the word
infons means
not yet speaking
uh children will acquire speech as we
find him narrating by chapter
8 and
you know until then
they're they're just little wriggling
things right driven by certain instincts
but also
quite malleable
as we'll find out and augustine points
out that none of us remember our infancy
so how do we
know anything about it
and he tells us that i was doing these
things how does he actually know well
he's heard from other people so
testimony is an important part of that
and then we see lots and lots of other
babies i mean one might say well i don't
see lots of babies you know i come from
a small family or i don't know anybody
else well in ancient times you couldn't
go anywhere without seeing some babies
somewhere and so augustine has seen a
lot of them and he's engaged in some
observation
and so what can we say about
infants he says that the very first
things that they do are pretty basic so
they
they nurse at the breast and he's got
some interesting reflections here about
the milk of the breasts and that you
know he's being fed by this
and yet you know
who where is the milk actually coming
from it's not coming directly from god
like you know doing a miracle every time
but the way that god has set up the
natural world mammals which we are
produce milk for their young and can
even you know get it from somebody else
some other uh person or some other
species as we do with cow's milk for
example
and so they nurse and that's a very very
basic instinct lacking this of course
they wouldn't continue in existence and
so that's very important and then
augustine tells us that they do other
things they're satisfied with pleasant
things what are infants like you know
being cuddled
being talked to being bathed and being
clean being nice and warm and then they
cry at things that hurt or disturb them
loud noises
too much light
some might be afraid of the dark
you know food that doesn't uh suit them
right
having all sorts of things going wrong
with their body like needing to be
burped we could go on and on and on
and so that's what infants do at first
and then augustine says a little bit
later on
they start to do other things and it's
really interesting
to see the first thing that he talks
about
laughing
laughing is something
that is essential to human beings but is
not the essence of human beings we are a
laughing animal augustine will actually
talk about this in other works as well
and it's something that is really core
but it's not it it's not the essence of
us
but it's quite important perceiving
perceiving literally
where ooby where one is
spatiality right beginning to perceive
the world and then we get to something
really central to augustine's thinking
making one's wants or desires or quite
literally one's
willingness one volitions
known
to other people and he the latin says
voluntates
volabaum ostende
you notice that the
volo
route is in there in volontantes and in
volabaum i
willed i
wished to
show to
indicate my
willingness so the will is already in
infants
through the function of communication
through the function of connecting with
other people
rather complicated and reflexive it is
the will
by which i will to make my wills or
willings or the what it is that i will
clear or at least apparent to other
beings
so
this is quite important and he says that
this has been told to me concerning
myself there's the testimony i believe
it because we see other infants acting
thus though i don't remember such acts
of my own
thus little by little i perceived where
i was and i wish to make my wants known
to those who could satisfy them right
those who could actually deal with it
yet i could not do so
why
well because those
wants are inside of me
there's a little interior world
that doesn't actually interface that
well with the outside world so what do i
do
so i tossed my limbs about and uttered
sounds thus making such few signs
similar to my wishes as i could now
that's worth thinking about you know
what is doing this ah you know the sort
of things that babies do how is that
similar
to what i want inside of me i mean at
least if you're if you're like smiling
and you want somebody else to smile
there's some similarity there but change
me give me food you know hold me pick me
up those are that similar to waving your
arms about but that's the best that the
infant can do right
so he says
those outside could by no sensible means
penetrate into my soul right but they
could figure out what i wanted and when
they would not obey me either because
they did not understand or because it
would be harmful
now that's putting a nice face on it
sometimes we just ignore babies because
we're worn out we don't want to you know
we don't want to do what the baby wants
us to do but when when they're not being
um obeyed then he he gets angry anger
and crying when not understood or
satisfied i grew angry at older ones who
were not subject to me and at children
for not waiting to me and i took it out
on them
by crying and you know anybody who
anybody who's had a baby knows what this
is like
then he goes on
and he tells us
that
children
infants
are sinful
and you know we could talk about
original sin which is a somewhat
different topic but he's actually saying
that some of the volitions some of the
willings that's where sin resides
are bad
and he he tells us
in your sight he's talking to god no man
is clean of sin not even the infant who
has lived but a day on earth does not
each little child now do this for in him
i perceive what i do not remember about
myself how did i sin at that age was it
because i cried out as i tried to mouth
the breast
indeed if i did so now not of course is
one gaping for the breast but for food
fitting to my years i would be laughed
at and most justly blamed you know if i
was like eating cry eating as we say
like and i'm eating spaghetti i'm like
oh i'm just not eating my spaghetti you
know something like that
what's wrong with this guy right
infants do that and we're like well
that's just the way babies are
he goes on though and he says that
i did reprehensible things but
infants get a pass
why they
don't understand that what they're doing
isn't what they ought to be doing that
it's something they should be blamed for
all they really understand is they've
got desires and they're trying to
express them and they're not they're not
coming out right
and reason and custom
don't blame
infants for that sort of thing you know
if we think it through or if we look at
our typical behavior towards infants we
don't actually blame them for that sort
of stuff we say oh you know it's just
the way they are
so we don't think of these as
bad and he says though when we get older
we try to root out these things and
throw them aside
and he says
even then were these things good to try
to get by crying even what would be
harmful
if it were given to me to be bitterly
resentful that free men elders my
parents and many other prudent people
who had not indulged my whims when i
struck at them and tried to hurt them as
far as i could because they did not obey
orders that could would only be obeyed
to my harm was that was that a a good
thing or a bad thing and he says no
these are bad things you know the infant
doesn't know what's good for it
at least you know
to some degree and you shouldn't indulge
the infant's whims and desires and so he
goes on and he says the infant's limbs
are harmless they can't really hurt
anybody with their you know hitting them
and stuff like that
but their wills their volitions
are not harmless
he says i have myself seen and had
experience with a jealous little one it
was not yet able to speak but it was
pale and bitter in face as it looked at
another child nursing at the same breath
so there's like a basic
self-centeredness to infants and that's
part of our our fallen human nature
according to
augustine now what happens when we
develop speech this is a chapter that is
often chapter eight often misunderstood
and
not read carefully enough so that people
attribute to augustine a theory of
linguistic development that he's not
actually advancing what does he say
i was no longer an infant one who could
not speak now i was a chattering boy i
remember this and afterwards i reflected
on how i learned to talk how i learned
to communicate with other people
grown-up people did not teach me by
presenting me with words in any orderly
form of instruction that will come later
as they did my letters but i myself with
the mind which you my god gave me wished
by means of various cries and sounds and
movements to express what to express my
heart's feelings the
senses cordis man what's what's in my
heart what it is i want to say and
what i want my volitions so language
is not just something where you're like
oh doggy oh
kitty cat oh
food stuff like that it's connected with
our desires our needs our wants our
demands the things that we
need or want to express to other people
so he says i was unable to express all
that i wished
or to all whom i wished and i pondered
over this in memory
how did i actually learn that so this is
the part where a lot of people get a
little bit tripped up
when they named a certain thing and at
that time made a gesture towards the
object i observed that object and
inferred it was called by the name they
uttered when they wished to show it to
me a little bit later he says
little by little
i infer that the words said in their
various places in different sentences
that i heard frequently were the signs
of things so a word is a sign of
something just like you know a cross
on a book is a sign a symbol you could
say of another cross the cross that
jesus died on or you know we can say
this about all sorts of other things a
tie
might be the sign of a certain bourgeois
respectability although if you loosen it
up maybe it's a sign that you're
actually kind of a you know a cool guy
who's willing to
to take things easy you know once the
work day is over the signs can be all
sorts of things and the words that i'm
speaking to you right now are also
signs now
is augustine claiming that every word is
a sign of one thing he is not
and notice
what's doing the heavy lifting we could
say it's not just pointing at something
and saying
you know
arf or doggy or
you know canis or something like that
there's a lot of other stuff involved
and he tells us what those things are in
part
he says that they meant this the sign
relation
was apparent why
bodily gestures
as it were by words natural to all men
which are made by change of countenance
the face
nods
movements
uh of the eyes and other bodily members
so there's a whole
we could call it meta communication
going on at the bodily level that goes
along with the words that are supposed
to
indicate the thing
and that's only half of what augustine
talks about
he also talks about the way in which we
use our voice
so he says that
sounds of the voice not just the words
but sounds of the voice which indicate
the affections of the mind
in
seeking possessing rejecting or avoiding
things right so this is also
necessary the way that we talk not just
the words that we say but the way that
we talk and the way that we use our
bodies
for children at least those who are
learning how to speak helps them learn
the
words so we say
doggy doggy you know and we point at it
and we like
direct our eyes look at that donkey over
there and eventually the kid you know
gets away from calling it moo cow or
kitty cat or something like that and
says doggie you know uh there used to be
this this toy called the uh say and you
would pull the lever and you'd have the
arrow on a particular
animal picture and it would say things
like the cow says moo
and that would make a moo sound or the
rooster says cock-a-doodle-doo you know
all these kind of funny words that
aren't exactly what the the animal says
but you know they're close enough right
that's how children learn
vocabulary and like he says
thus to those among whom i was com i was
i i communicated the signs of which i
wish to of what i wish to express i
entered more deeply into the society of
human life those still dependent on my
parents authority and the will of my
elders this learning language exiting
infancy is how we enter into
the social world
you